Transcription: Anne-Sophie Matichard
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
L'autre jour, j'attendais le bus
en bas de chez moi pour aller au boulot.
J'étais seule, perdue dans mes pensées
quand j'ai entendu le bus arriver.
Je me suis levée,
je me suis rapprochée du bord de la route,
et j'ai levé la main pour signaler
au chauffeur
que j'étais partante pour embarquer.
C'est là que j'ai vu passer
un camion toupie.
Bon,
il ne s'est pas arrêté,
il m'a plantée là,
toute seule, avec ma dignité.
Peut-être pensez-vous que
je suis une fille étourdie,
ou bien que j'étais saoule,
complètement bourrée,
mais en réalité,
je suis malvoyante, vraiment malvoyante.
Depuis mon adolescence,
je suis atteinte
d'un trouble de la vision centrale.
Donc en pratique,
quand vous regardez ce petit homme,
eh bien moi, je le vois comme ça.
Je n'ai pas de problème pour
voir les grands ensembles,
pour me déplacer,
mais la vision des détails,
ce n'est pas terrible.
Ça m'empêche de caractériser
précisément l'objet roulant
s'il est à plus de quelques mètres.
La lecture est aussi
une activité compliquée,
enfin sauf si la police est en 72.
Mais là,
un roman devient vite
légèrement encombrant.
Ce sont mes activités professionnelles
qui m'ont amenée à me questionner
sur la place des travailleurs handicapés
dans une organisation.
A priori, ce n'est pas gagné.
Parce que le taux de chômage
des travailleurs handicapés
est le double de la population moyenne.
Ces recherches ont attisé ma curiosité.
Je me suis renseignée,
formée sur le sujet,
et là, j'ai tiré sur des sujets emboîtés.
Les thèmes de la formation,
de l'éducation,
de l'accès aux bâtiments,
à l'espace public -
et je vais m'arrêter là parce que
sinon ça risque d'être un peu long -
mais tous ces thèmes se sont dévoilés.
Et franchement,
c'est à se demander !
C'est la société qui les cache,
ou c'est les personnes handicapées
qui se planquent ?
Hé hé !
Ce qui est sûr,
c'est qu'on retrouve
les personnes handicapées,
bien trop souvent,
à part.
Ce constat m'a personnellement interrogée.
Je veux dire, comment ça se fait que
j'ai réussi à déjouer les statistiques ?
Non parce que j'ai fait des études,
que j'ai choisies en plus,
je vis en couple,
je suis maman,
j'ai créé mon entreprise,
enfin...
franchement il apparaît que
j'appartiens à la vie ordinaire.
Certains diront que
c'est grâce à mon caractère.
Genre un peu tenace.
C'est pas faux,
mais cette seule explication
me paraît un peu courte.
Du coup, j'en rajouterais trois autres.
La première,
c'est que mon handicap
est quasi invisible.
Je vous l'ai dit, je vois l'essentiel.
Et pour les détails,
j'utilise des moyens de compensation.
Mon ordinateur est formidable,
il me lit tout,
et l'option appareil photo
de mon téléphone
me permet de zoomer tout, partout
et en toute discrétion.
J'use aussi de nombreuses stratégies
de contournement :
mon sourire,
ma mémoire et ma capacité d'adaptation
sont de sacrés atouts.
Je ne développe pas,
mais c'est une fine organisation
et beaucoup d'astuces pour contourner
les difficultés que je rencontre
au quotidien.
La deuxième chose
qui me paraît importante,
c'est que je n'ai jamais eu peur
du mot handicap.
Je revendique même une certaine fierté
d'appartenir à cette communauté
car au plus loin où remontent
mes souvenirs,
j'ai toujours eu des amis
en situation de handicap
et je me suis sentie
enrichie à leur contact.
Enfin,
la troisième chose fondamentale,
c'est que mes proches
m'ont toujours encouragée,
parfois au détriment
de leurs propres peurs d'ailleurs.
Leur présence rassurante m'a permis
de rester sourde
aux injections limitantes du style :
« Ne fais pas d'études, de toute manière
personne ne voudra t'embaucher. »
Aujourd'hui, je vis mon handicap
non pas comme une limite,
mais comme une opportunité.
Une opportunité de développer
ma sensibilité, ma créativité,
ma vision différente du monde.
C'est d'ailleurs grâce à cela
que je suis là devant vous,
que je suis consultante
en développement durable
et également formatrice
en pratiques inclusives.
Une société inclusive est le pilier social
incontournable d'un développement durable.
Il s'agit là d’une société qui permet
la participation de tous,
qui s’adapte, qui s'enrichit
des différences ;
qui lutte contre les exclusions
et les discriminations.
Alors je voulais vous donner
ma petite recette d’une société inclusive.
J'accentuerai cependant
mon propos sur le handicap,
certes parce que je suis concernée
mais également parce que,
cette année encore,
pour son dernier mandat,
le Défenseur des Droits de la République,
Jacques Toubon,
a confirmé que le handicap est
le premier critère de discrimination,
et ce avant la couleur de peau,
le genre ou l’orientation sexuelle.
Alors c’est parti.
Prenez un handicap.
Vous avez le choix.
Peut-être instinctivement,
opterez-vous pour un handicap physique,
sensoriel,
ou intellectuel.
Mais le champ du handicap est plus large.
Sont concernées également les personnes
porteuses d’un handicap psychique,
d’une maladie invalidante
ou d’un polyhandicap,
version la plus lourde
mais pas la moins intéressante.
Bon, Je ne vais pas me lancer
dans un listing exhaustif
qui répond à l’exercice de
catégorisation administrative, hein ?
Je pense qu'il y a 400 personnes
qui me remercient...
(Rires)
J’ai plutôt choisi de vous faire
toucher du doigt
l’importante diversité
des situations de handicap.
Maintenant que vous avez choisi,
accordez-vous un peu de temps
pour comprendre
les déficiences qui lui sont associées.
Je parle ici des difficultés quotidiennes
que rencontrent ces personnes.
Il y a plein de ressources merveilleuses
et très ludiques sur Internet
mais le must est de questionner
quelqu'un qui le vit.
Juste, à ce stade,
attention de ne pas
vous laisser gagner par la pitié,
elle ne construit rien de durable
ou par la condescendance,
elle nourrit la colère.
Alors on peut continuer.
Observez maintenant
les stratégies de contournement
que cette personne met en place
pour avancer dans la vie.
L’an passé,
j’ai animé une session de formation.
Je devais préparer des demandeurs d’emploi
à aborder leur handicap
dans un entretien d’embauche.
Dans cette session,
Tonio, technicien en bâtiment,
présentait des troubles de la mémoire
accentué par
un traitement antiépileptique.
Il avait du mal à retenir les astuces
que je donnais à l’oral
alors il écrivait tout sur son cahier,
méthodiquement et très soigneusement.
Au-delà de sa motivation,
j’ai été marquée par
son savoir-être ultra agréable.
Et en détaillant son CV,
j’ai noté sa quinzaine
d’années d'expérience
passées dans plusieurs
grandes entreprises de la place.
Je pensais tenir là une belle piste
d’optimisme pour les autres stagiaires.
Alors je lui ai demandé de nous raconter
comment il avait réussi
à concilier son handicap
et sa vie professionnelle.
Il s’est trouvé un peu emprunté
et il nous a répondu :
« En fait,
je n’ai jamais dit à tous mes collègues,
tous mes patrons,
que j’avais une reconnaissance de handicap
parce qu'à chaque fois que je l’ai dit
dans un entretien d’embauche,
on ne m’a jamais recruté.
Alors toutes ces années,
je n'ai rien dit,
j’ai feinté,
personne ne le sait. »
J'avoue, là il m'a sciée.
Je ne m’attendais pas vraiment
à cette réponse.
Alors Je lui ai demandé de nous raconter
comment il avait fait.
En fait, quand Tonio prend un poste,
il se concentre à fond et il note tout
dans un petit cahier :
ce qu’il doit faire,
l'enchaînement des opérations,
les informations particulières,
les horaires.
Il garde toujours son cahier sur lui.
Comme ça, s’il a un trou,
il se met discrètement dans un coin,
reprend ses notes et là il se rappelle.
Quelques semaines plus tard,
je croise une copine qui bossait
dans la dernière entreprise
où Tonio était en poste.
et parce que je suis curieuse
et que je n’avais pas vraiment
saisi le contexte de son départ,
je lui ai demandé de m'expliquer
pourquoi l'entreprise l'avait remercié.
Elle m'a raconté :
« On lui a fait un
licenciement économique,
on n’avait plus de contrat
dans son secteur
et puis lui il avait d’autres projets.
Mais je ne me fais pas de soucis pour lui,
c’est un gars super,
un employé en or, ultra performant. »
Elle a marqué une pause,
elle m’a regardée avec
des grands yeux tout ronds.
Et elle a rajouté :
« Mais comment tu le connais ?
Il est handicapé, lui ? »
Est-ce que vous l’avez là ?
La puissance des stratégies
de contournement ?
Elle ouvre le champ des possibles.
Et franchement,
Tonio n’est pas un cas isolé,
il suffit juste d'accepter
de se laisser surprendre.
Normalement à ce stade de l’exposé,
on est bon sur le changement de regard.
Et c’est bien là l’essentiel.
Mais au-delà des prises de conscience,
une société inclusive a besoin de la
mobilisation de toutes nos compétences.
Les chantiers sont nombreux,
l’enjeu est de taille.
mais les bénéfices profiteront à tous,
oui tous.
Car nous vivrons chacun en moyenne huit
ans de notre vie en situation de handicap
Et dans 80 % des cas,
ce handicap sera invisible.
Alors, il y a du boulot
pour tout le monde !
Parmi vous,
il y en a qui pourront s'imprégner
des principes
de l’accessibilité universelle.
Ceux qui pourront s'engager dans
la voie du management de la diversité,
du management par les compétences.
Certains pourront adapter
leur communication
grâce à la méthode
« Facile à Lire et à Comprendre »,
et d’autres encore,
par exemple,
pourront porter leurs efforts sur
une approche positive de la différence.
Bref,
quoi qu'il en soit,
gardez toujours en tête
cette diversité des handicaps,
cette attention particulière à avoir,
cette palette incroyable de solutions
humaines et techniques,
cette adaptation souvent mineure
qui facilitera la participation de tous.
C’est là que vous serez acteur
d’une société inclusive.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)